is the function given below continuous
slash differentiable at x equals one and
they define the function g piecewise
right over here and then they give us a
bunch of choices continuous but not
differentiable differentiable but not
continuous both continuous and
differentiable neither continuous nor
differentiable and like always pause
this video and see if you could figure
this out so let's do step by step so
first let's think about continuity so
for continuity for g to be continuous at
x equals one that means that g of one
that means that g of 1 must be equal to
the limit as x approaches 1 of g of g of
x
well g of 1 what is that going to be g
of 1 we're going to fall into this clock
this case
1 minus 1 squared is going to be 0.
so if we can show that the limit of g of
x as x approaches 1 is the same as g of
1 is equal to 0 then we know we're
continuous there let's do the left and
right handed limits here so if we do the
left-handed limit limit and that's
especially useful because we're in these
different clauses here as we approach
from the left and the right-hand side so
as x approaches 1 from the left-hand
side of
g of x
well we're going to be falling into this
situation here as we approach from the
left as x is less than 1. so this is
going to be the same thing as
that that's what g of x is equal to when
we are less than 1 as we're approaching
from the left
well this thing is is defined and it's
continuous for all real numbers so we
can just substitute 1 in for x and we
get this is equal to 0. so so far so
good let's do one more of these let's
approach from the right hand side as x
approaches 1 from the right-hand side of
g of x well now we're falling into this
case so g of x if we're to the right of
1 if we're great values greater than or
equal to 1 it's going to be x minus 1
squared well once again x minus 1
squared that is defined for all real
numbers it's continuous for all real
numbers so we could just pop that 1 in
there you get 1 minus 1 squared well
that's just 0 again
so the left hand limit the right hand
limit are both equal 0 which means that
the limit is equal the limit of g of x
as x approaches one is equal to zero
which is the same thing as g of one so
we are good with continuity so we can
rule out all the ones that are saying
that they are it's not continuous so we
could rule out that one
and
we can rule out that one right over
there so now let's think about whether
it is differentiable so
differentiability
so differentiability all right
ability
did i let's see that's a long word
differentiability
all right differentiability what needs
to be true here well we have to have a
defined limit as x approaches 1 for
f of x minus f of 1
over oh let me be careful it's not f
it's g of it's g so we need to have a
defined limit for
g of x
minus g of 1
over
x
minus 1.
and so let's just try to evaluate this
limit from the left and right hand sides
and we could simplify it we already know
that g of 1 is 0. so that's just going
to be 0. so we just need to find the
limit as x approaches one of g of x over
x minus one or see if we can find the
limit so let's first think about the
limit
as we approach from the left hand side
of
g of x
over
x
minus g of x over x minus 1. well as we
approach from the left hand side g of x
is that right over there so we should we
could write this instead of writing g of
x we could write this as x minus 1
x minus 1 over x minus 1. and as long as
we aren't equal to 1 this thing is going
to be equal as long as x does not equal
x minus 1 over x minus 1 is just going
to be 1. so this limit is going to be 1.
so that was that one worked out now
let's think about the limit
as x approaches 1 from the right hand
side of once again i could write g of x
minus g of 1 but g of 1 is just 0 so
i'll just write g of x
over
x minus 1.
well what's g of x now well it's x minus
1 squared so instead of writing g of x i
could write this as
x
minus 1 squared over x minus 1.
and so as long as x does not equal one
we're just doing the limit we're saying
as we approach 1 from the right hand
side well this expression right over
here you have x minus 1 squared divided
by x minus 1 well that's just going to
give us x minus 1. x minus 1 squared
divided by x minus 1 is just going to be
x minus 1.
and this limit well this expression
right over here is going to be
continuous and defined for
for sure all x's that are not equaling
1. actually let me
let me well
it was it was before it was this x minus
squared over x minus 1. this thing right
over here as i said it's not defined for
x equals 1 but it is defined for
anything not for x does not equal 1 and
we're just approaching 1 and if we
wanted to simplify this expression it
would get
we this would just be i think i just did
this but i'm just making sure i'm doing
it right
this is going to be the same thing as
that for x not being equal to 1 well
this is just going to be 0. you can just
evaluate when x is equal to 1 here this
is going to be equal to 0. and so notice
you get a different limit for this
definition of the derivative as we
approach from the left-hand side or the
right-hand side and that makes sense
this graph is going to look something
like
we have a slope of 1 so it's going to
look something like this
and then
right when x is equal to one and the
value of our function is zero
it looks something like this
it looks something like this and so the
graph is continuous
the graph for sure is continuous but our
slope coming into that point is one and
our slope right when we leave that point
is zero so it is not differentiable over
there so it is continuous but not
continuous but not differentiable